welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and normally i try and do
some witty intro
but i just want to give a big rest and
peace to jeremy bullock who played boba
fett in the original star wars trilogy
jeremy left a huge impression that
pretty much made baba one of the coolest
characters in the galaxy
and without his performance it's highly
doubtful that we would be here right now
talking about this episode it's sad that
he died just before one of the big
announcements in this entry
and my thoughts go out to all his
friends and family now episode 8 is the
finale
and what a way to close out the season
it is last week we ended on the
cliffhanger that mando was basically
doing a liam neeson
and coming for grow goo no matter what
however
he doesn't do it alone and this episode
brings back not only poketan
but also luke skywalker who will be
training the child
i never thought that they would actually
bring him back and i was so happy to be
proven wrong
as he completely elevated this episode
because of his appearance
the show also has a post-credits scene
that confirms a boba fett show is coming
in 2021
and that will be titled the book of
bobber we're going to be breaking it all
down of course but we start with slave 1
chasing down an imperial shuttle which
has dr pershing riding on it as a
passenger
you may remember from season 1 that
pershing was actually the character that
wanted to keep the child alive
after the client said he could be killed
and he comes across as more of a good
guy under the control of the empire
instead of just an evil scientist slave
1 manages to disable the shuttle by
hitting it with an iron cannon
which is pretty much the star wars
equivalent of an emp
they then board which is where we get a
great exchange from one of the imperial
officers
if you followed our agents of shield
breakdowns then you may remember
this is the guy that also played
nathaniel malek and i love how he's a
complete imperial loyalist
that doesn't mind blasting his mate and
painting himself into a corner
he taunts cara over alderaan and says
that he witnessed the planet being
destroyed
something he takes great joy in i love
how angry he gets over her asking which
death star he was on
and the guy probably lost a lot of
friends which is which is why such a
villain i
i know you're a good guy now after
commandeering the shuttle
they journey to balkatan and you can
actually spot her gauntlet
ship which looks completely awesome
she's joined by costco reeves played by
sasha banks
but unfortunately axe wolves isn't there
they never bring up y
so i don't know what's happened to the
character but hopefully we will see him
back further down the line
beau kind of looks down on fed for being
a clone and as we know the law has gone
back and forth over whether he's a true
mandalorian or not
though it was confirmed he was he also
said he never said he was a mandalorian
so let the debates continue once more
affect talks about how mandalore was
turned to glass and that it's pointless
taking it back
the planet was completely wracked with
not only civil war but also
separatist and imperial invasions which
left it a complete wasteland
glasses of course made from sand so i
really appreciated this remark
he and sasha go head to head after she
says she didn't know the sidekick was
allowed to talk
and it's the star wars equivalent of the
pot calling the kettle black
which means they go face to face they
even use
the same weapons as each other and i
love how there's the kind of mirroring
of the past and future here as we watch
them duke it out
now as we know from episode 3 of the
season beau wants nothing more than to
take down moth gideon
and get the darksaber back thus the
group will come to a deal
and decide to join forces i love how the
imperials
almost got what they wanted and had them
fighting themselves for a bit instead of
them
and this was pretty much how they
managed to seize mandalore as the
inhabitants were at constant war with
one another
they scanned them off freighter and
perishing also brings up the dark
troopers
stating that their third generation and
no longer relying on soldiers
originally they were troopers who had
abilities that belonged to the dark side
and this made them adept at fighting for
the empire however as time went on
the imperials decided to iron out the
failures and they eventually replaced
the humans with droids
so that they would serve without failure
using the lambda shuttle
the group make it seem like they're
imperial forces being attacked
and it's one of the smartest sneaking on
board something plans that i've ever
seen
it's upon landing on the ship that
things really ramp up and we watch as
the girls get it done and create a
distraction
whilst mano makes his way to the child
see marvel
this is how you do girl power without
forcing it now mano passes a droid that
looks similar to 3b6 or a7
who you may remember from a new hope and
rogue one
this little soft dude scuttles off as
fast as he can
and it's the complete opposite to what
comes later with the dark troopers
during this fight i got a lot of vibes
of batman v superman
alongside the terminator however using
the best score spear that he got from
the magistrate
he's able to take it out and blast the
dark troopers out the airlock
now as we guessed the spear is used
against the darksaber so that mano can
combat maf gideon
without getting completely annihilated i
think it was really smart to set it up
as a powerful weapon against
ahsoka as that kind of let us know that
it would be able to handle the ancient
sword
carl also says the phrase dank farrick
which is a curse where that's popped up
throughout the season
so i'm glad they keep using it as it
manages to keep the show pg-13
now all that aside gideon confirms that
the blood taken from groku will not only
be used to create snoke
but also grant force abilities to the
emperor's clone
which was likely being worked on in
episode 4. he doesn't really seem
too attached to the child and dangles
the dark saber above his head
showing that he has likely completed his
goal in perfecting the technique
now gideon could have just killed grogu
but i actually think that he kept him
around because he knew the emperor would
be looking for a new apprentice
and that if they could corrupt him young
that they would have a powerful ally on
their side
gideon knows that beau wants the
darksaber and tricks manu into thinking
that the two have made a deal
that will get him out alive he says that
if he lets him live
he can have the child and that they can
go their separate ways
and it's it's all gonna be so so happy
he is the bad guy though so of course
he's lying
and he lashes out which leads to mando
and the moth going head-to-head
it's an awesome action scene and
honestly if this had been the height of
the episode
then i think i would have been happy
however things obviously go beyond it
amano takes them off to the bridge
after sparing his life now there's a
really tense moment in which mano goes
to hand the darksaber over to beau
but as the moth says the rules of
mandalore dictate that one cannot be
given it
and they must win or rather earn it in
order to become the leader of the planet
mano tries to talk his way out of it by
yielding but as gideon says
it's not just the blade it's the story
that goes with it
we don't actually see the resolution to
this and moth says she'll perhaps get
another crack at it
meaning that currently mando is the
leader of mandalore
well well his name is the mandalorian i
suppose
oh but i think going forward beau will
take it back
as it's just so heavily written into a
story that it would be stupid to not
actually let her gain the position
as is being shown in season 2 there are
loopholes
and ways that you can interpret the
mandalorian rules and depending on what
sect you're part of
they can be taken differently sabine did
give the possession of the darksaber
over the bowen rebels
as she said she was the one who was most
fit for the position
so who knows what's even happening yeah
i think they kind of get lost in their
own continuity sometimes as
to me yeah you can just hand it over but
i guess not
now i think it will be a big point in
season three that we will see them going
face to face
which is why they brought it up here i
could of course be wrong
but this is one of the big plot threads
that is still left dangling by the end
of the series
so it does make a lot of sense now
before they pit it out
the dark troopers that were blasted out
of the airlock return and they brought
some reinforcements
it looks like death is certain for the
group until we see a familiar-looking
x-wing flying into the hangar
now although how this show has dropped
the ships in first to tease things
and leaves you as an audience member
thinking no wait
wait is it now this was actually leaked
this week
and after seeing the soundtrack many
eagle-eyed viewers noticed that elements
of luke's theme were being used in it
so this did tip people off that he was
returning as soon as we saw the famous
dark cloak coming in it
it could only be one person and luke
completely tears them all up
now if you've watched our predictions
video then you'll know he said that
because of the logistics of having luke
that we didn't think him coming back was
a possibility
this was because of hamel's age and how
difficult it would be to de-age him
and i just didn't think that it would be
the route that they would take but they
cleverly obscure his face for most of it
that is until the end which is when we
see him standing still and even then
uh even then it looks a bit um i don't
know just use sebastian stan next time
yeah
now his arrival makes the moth realize
that he and his forces have lost
so he grabs a gun and tries to take down
who he can
however due to the best score armor this
fails and thus the character turns the
gun on himself
at the last second though kara manages
to stop him ending his own life
and we do know that giancarlo esposito
will be in the third season
so expect to see him playing a central
role in things going forward
i think he will likely escape and remain
is the big bad
but it would be great to have the team
spend some proper time with him
so he could learn his true backstory and
why he ended up the way he did
now luke takes grogu and mando actually
removes his helmet
they almost asked who he is and i was
really hoping that he'd say brown eyes
brown eyes skywalker however that bit is
skipped over
and instead he has a touching farewell
that will bring a tear to the eye of
even the most hardened sith lord
i kind of got a lot of similarities here
with luke saying farewell to his father
after removing the darth vader helmet
and though the positions are flipped
i definitely think that they are sort of
playing on that moment i have to say
though that it was excellently acted
i love how this entire show has
basically revolved around mando finding
the person that would make him drop the
rules
in order to embrace his humanity clearly
that came here
and it's an excellent way to close
things out r2d2
arrives as well and this was an amazing
bit of fan service that already topped
off what was an incredible scene
they take grogu to luke's jedi academy
and to a fate
that we don't know yet however as we
learn from the force awakens
kylo ren carried out a jedi purge here
and it seems like grosgu
is going to be thrown in the deep end
once more as he will of course be in a
similar position to how he was with
order 66.
we do know that grogu isn't in the
sequel trilogy and i actually think that
mando might end up taking him from the
academy before things go down
gregory seems very apprehensive about
going with luke
amanda even initially says that he
doesn't want to until he gives
permission
so there will likely be some regret
there the sequel trilogy also takes
place roughly
25 to 30 years after return of the jedi
and as the series is set five years
after the events of that movie
there is plenty of time for him to train
and be gone so grogu may indeed survive
i
i
tell you what he better and be in a
completely different part of the galaxy
when kylo creates his uprising
obviously there's a lot that can be
taken from that but
him being carried over luke's shoulder
instead of how he was with mando's
shows that he's lost his boy and it's a
very bittersweet way
to close things out i love you croco
i love you [ __ ] now before we get into
the post credits scene i'd massively
appreciate it if you hit the thumbs up
button
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel because we've got a hell of a
lot more manual things to talk about
over the coming weeks
don't forget we're giving away three
free copies of the lord of the rings 4k
box set and all you have to do to win
one is drop a comment below
and make sure you subscribe with
notifications on anyway
after some very long credits we come
back to jabba's palace
and see that bib fortuna has taken over
as the ruler of his criminal empire
the guy seems to be just lounging about
and though he's basically operating with
a skeleton crew in comparison to what
the hut had
he still commands a lot of forces
however it doesn't last too long and we
watch as fenekshan enters before bubba
arrives
kills bib and takes the throne this is
an incredible moment
and if you watch the star wars disney
ambassador panel
you are probably surprised to learn that
there wasn't a boba fett show announced
leaks had confirmed that it was being
filmed but we didn't really get
anything dropped at the event so people
didn't know whether it had been
cancelled or not now there are rumors
that this is actually going to be the
third season of the mandalorian
and it is releasing in december which is
the month that the following from this
was meant to be
i'm making this video right after things
have aired so if it has been announced
yet and we do know the details
apologies but yeah just kind of making
this first thing
now bubba's book does sort of sound like
an add-on to me
rather than its own complete spin-off
but either way i'm glad he's going to be
back as
i genuinely thought they were going to
kill him off the soundtrack also had a
song in it called rest in peace
so i was sure it was going to either be
him or cara however both make it out
alive
it's an incredible way to close things
out and watching him take the throne is
the best thing that they could have done
with the character
now that is the series over and i feel
we can look back and say that this is
the best live-action star wars property
to come out in the past 10 years
my opinion anyway bar episode 2 i think
this just hit it out the park every
single week
and it's so good that i tried watching
the first season again
and due to the lack of big characters in
the beginning it felt like something was
slightly missing
now we know that isn't really the case
but that's exactly what a show should do
in numerous entries
i think back to game of thrones and how
much i loved season one
but then after two three four five and
six came out
it just paled in comparison this on the
most part ticked all the boxes for me
and had there not been a second episode
which was just fella to me
i think it would have gotten the perfect
score still mando was incredible
and i can't wait to see season 3 which
is due to premiere on christmas day 2021
i hope you had a blast going through the
episodes with me and thank you everyone
who stopped by the channel every week to
watch the breakdowns
now before we go i just want to let you
know i'm doing a big spoiler stream for
suicide prevention on sunday
over at the den of the nerds live
channel we're going to be going over all
the spoilers that we've heard on the
cider cut
spider-man 3 wonder woman 84 and a lot
more
it's for an incredible cause and
hopefully we see it over there
now if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the wonder woman 1984 post
credits scene which will be linked on
screen right now
we break down the entire thing so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more
without all the way thank you for
sitting through the video the force will
be with you always
i've been paul and i'll see you next
time take care peace